[Música]
el hombre que vemos es un representante
del líder supremo de Irán fue grabado en
una ciudad turística del Sur del país el
mismo fue Ordenar el cierre de cualquier
establecimiento en el que las mujeres no
usaran el velo islámico tras meses de
protestas contra el poder religioso
estas imágenes son el último ejemplo de
los intentos de las autoridades por
hacer cumplir los códigos de vestimenta
islámicos represiones que a veces llegan
hasta la imposición de multas la
prohibición de utilizar el transporte
público e incluso el acceso aeropuertos
y hospitales a las mujeres que se niegan
a aportar el
pulgar
[Música]
Incluso se les ha pedido a los
comerciantes que les exijan a sus
clientas el uso del hiyap o de lo
contrario sus negocios serán cerrados
pero las mujeres iraníes afirman que
esta represión no les impedirá luchar
por las libertades sociales una de ellas
es nuestra observadora a quien
llamaremos pendar no escucharán su voz
sino la de una actriz que leerá su
testimonio hoy en día solo me pongo una
camisa y un pantalón nada más y eso
nunca ha sido un problema para mí
durante las últimas vacaciones de norus
Viajé a muchas ciudades y visité muchos
lugares turísticos y no tuve ningún
problema las autoridades intentan
enfrentar a los comerciantes con la
gente pero no lo logran hay videos de
mujeres en gillaba las que se les
deniega la entrada aeropuertos o
estaciones de metro
tenemos la sensación de que la República
islámica está haciendo esto
principalmente para que sus partidarios
puedan decir miren no nos hemos rendido
lucharemos En mi opinión no hay nada que
puedan hacer al respecto millones de
mujeres rechazan el uso obligatorio del
llave y la República islámica no tiene
ni la mano de obra ni el dinero para
perseguir a millones de mujeres
[Aplausos]
la policía prometió empezar a tomar
medidas drásticas pero yo seguí usando
la misma ropa no tenía miedo y me sentía
más apoyada por la gente en la calle las
autoridades incluso crearon una
plataforma oficial en la que Los
partidarios del régimen pueden denunciar
a las conductoras que vean sin velo los
usuarios pueden señalar el número de
placa del vehículo y luego la
propietaria del auto Recibe un mensaje
con una multa y una advertencia este es
uno de esos mensajes
se trata de un error tiene 48 horas para
pelear a través de este enlace si
reincide su vehículo será confiscado
Pero las mujeres iraníes encontraron una
manera de burlar esta tecnología Si
vemos un auto en el que va una mujer
boxeador reportamos el número de placa a
la plataforma para que su base de datos
no funcione el caos resultante hará que
la plataforma sea totalmente ineficaz un
portavoz de la policía iraní afirmó
haber recibido miles de mensajes
denunciando a conductoras que no
respetaban el código vestimentario la
policía también señala que han cerrado
138 tiendas y 18 restaurantes y esto
solamente durante el 15 de abril por no
respetar el uso del jab sin embargo la
redacción de los observadores no pudo
verificar esta cifra de manera
independiente
[Música]
el 21 de abril en pretoria en el noreste
de Sudáfrica la policía desplegó varios
vehículos frente a la oficina del alto
comisionado de las Naciones Unidas para
los refugiados el objetivo era desalojar
a un centenar de solicitantes de asilo y
refugiados que acampaban en este lugar
entre ellos se encuentra cereza
refugiada de la República democrática
del Congo con la que hablamos justo
después del desalojo
delante de la oficina de acnur había
mucha gente
fueron a desalojar a 31 familias que
estaban acampando allá
nos quedamos 11 meses frente a acnur
antes de que nos expulsaran
el desalojo del campamento de refugiados
se produjo tras más de tres años de
peticiones para reubicar a estas
personas en otro país hablamos con Luis
duplecis abogada especialista en
derechos humanos que ha seguido de cerca
el caso ya no se sienten seguros en
Sudáfrica y por una buena razón en 2019
se produjeron graves ataques xenófobos
algunos de ellos perdieron familiares
como consecuencia directa de estos
ataques
por eso decidieron instalarse frente a
la oficina del acnur para pedir ser
reubicados en un tercer país el acnur es
muy estricto en cuanto a la reubicación
de refugiados después en 2019 los
hombres fueron detenidos por
allanamiento de morada y las mujeres
fueron llevadas a lindela
un centro de detención Teresa la
refugiada congoleña pasó tres años en
lindela y guarda muy malos recuerdos de
aquella época lindela es un campo de
concentración
solo nos daban papillas por la mañana
dos rebanadas de pan sin nada más
no había felicidad ni agua caliente no
podíamos salir tras ser liberados en
mayo de 2022 los refugiados no tenían a
dónde ir y volvieron a las instalaciones
de acnur el viernes 21 de abril podría
haber resultado peor fue muy tenso
después de que los desalojaran de las
oficinas del acnur
terminaron en un parque
y entonces la situación se tornó
extremadamente tensa la policía les
decía ahora vamos a restarlos
afortunadamente una mujer se ofreció
alojarlos En una granja
estas personas están muy traumatizadas
algunas tienen graves problemas de Salud
Mental no reciben ninguna atención No
creo que tengan muchas esperanzas
Laura paduán portavoz de acnur dijo
sentirse aliviada de que la acción
policial para desalojar a quienes
acampaban se hubiera desarrollado de
manera pacífica 18 personas fueron al
indela y setenta se quedaron en la
granja afirmó también que la reubicación
de refugiados en un tercer país no
entraba dentro del mandato de acnur
así llegamos al final de los
observadores por esta semana si quieren
informarnos sobre una historia o
enviarnos sus imágenes todos nuestros
contactos aparecen en pantalla Este es
un programa hecho con ustedes Así que no
duden en contarnos lo que ocurre en sus
comunidades hasta la próxima semana